stéphane augé chef du service de
réanimation pédiatrique à l'hôpital
robert debré bonsoir c'est cet objet
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france edouard philippe qui promet donc
un que le quotidien des personnels
soignant à l'hôpital changerait dans les
tons prochains mois ça laisse présager
des changements concrets pour vous la
crise du prix droit au moins servi à
cela
bonsoir madame on voit pas les choses
vraiment comme ça comme vous le savez ça
fait très longtemps qu'on crie que
l'hôpital public ne fonctionnent plus
correctement en tous les cas n'est plus
en adéquation avec les besoins de la
population
je pense que ça a mis la loupe
grossissante sur les difficultés qu'on a
réussi à surmonter mais qui reste majeur
donc pour l'instant on va plus pouvoir
se payer de mots c'est pour ça qu'on a
sorti un manifeste qu'on a travaillé
qu'on a tous fait des propositions c'est
quasiment plus de 50 pages qui ont été
écrites par de nombreux professionnels
des directeurs des économistes pour
arriver sur la table de négociation avec
des propositions
il nous faut des gestes forts tout de
suite pour qu'après on puisse se mettre
au travail si ce même c'est très très
court pour réformer l'hôpital les
systèmes de santé j'ai un peu de doute
mais en tous les cas le collectif inter
hôpitaux le collectif inter urgence moi
je parle pour le cih et très motivé et a
envie que ça avance donc nous avons fait
des propositions
nous voulons des gestes forts tout de
suite et après nous sommes au travail
avec l'ensemble des partenaires
on en a évidemment parlé plusieurs fois
mais il faut le répéter effectivement la
veille de l'ouverture de ce secteur de
la santé vous dites des gestes forts
tout de suite
quels sont vos archives si je peux me
permettre de m'exprimer ainsi
vos archives priorité
elles sont très simples alors d'abord
nous sommes un mouvement qui réunit
toutes sortes de professionnels de
l'hôpital public et en plus des usagers
qui ont créé ce mouvement il ya
maintenant plusieurs mois à la suite du
cio rappelé au début de l'automne année
dernière pour lequel ont été votées des
principales motion d'urgence
il était hors de question de l'échangé
depuis les et derniers événements la
première revendication très forte c'est
effectivement une augmentation salariale
est un geste fort tout de suite avant la
mise en route de négociations par
branches en fonction des statuts ça ce
sont nos collègues des syndicats qui les
porteront mais on veut un geste tout de
suite de reconnaissance des personnels
la deuxième c'est un moratoire immédiat
sur l'arrêt des fermetures de lits je
pense que là aussi le co vide l'a
parfaitement démontré on a manqué de
lits dans certaines régions faute
d'organisation il faut arrêter de fermer
des lits redonner la main aux régions et
aux territoires pour réfléchir à quel
endroit on peut en ré ouvrir en ré
ouvrir plus voir arrêter d'en ouvrir
dans certains autres ça ça doit être une
décision locale
en tous les cas prises avec l'ensemble
des personnels et puis il faut troisième
geste fort sur la gouvernance qu'on n'a
jamais réussi à obtenir pour une seule
raison c'est que le gouvernement ne
voulait pas investir dans l'hôpital
public à la hauteur des besoins
s'il décide de le faire on va regarder
qu'il donne aussi la main au personnel
et aux usagers pour arriver frais
réellement à gouverner correctement
l'hôpital public parmi les gestes forts
parmi les premiers que vous ne citiez on
imagine qu'il ya là la hausse des
salaires pour se hisser dans la moyenne
nationale est ce que vous avez un
chiffre à nous annoncer nous avancer
dans vos souhaits
écoutez le chiffre pour lequel on avait
voté et qui est là et qui ne tombe pas
du ciel qui correspond pour en tous les
cas des personnels paramédicaux à la
mise à niveau suite au gel du point
d'indicé durant dix ans c'est 300 euros
par mois net pour les personnels
paramédicaux ça encore c'est une
revendication qui a été voté par
l'ensemble des professionnels du
collectif nous voulons un geste fort et
nous sommes prêts à prêt à réfléchir à
la mise en route des négociations
l'évolution salariale mais il faut un
geste fort ce chiffre peut servir de
référence il correspond à au manque à
gagner les personnels et en plus les
remets exactement dans la médiane où la
moyenne des salaires des postes
équivalents en europe 5 a annoncé par
edouard philippe la reconnaissance pour
nos soignants l'investissement massif
l'agilité retrouver l'organisation
territoriale et enfin la modernisation
par le numérique est ce que selon vous
ces axes vont dans le bon sens
oh je pense que ce sont des gros groupes
de travail qui sont tout à fait
intéressant et qui peuvent tout à fait
permettre d'en savoir plus et d'avancer
correctement
il n'empêche que il faut voir ce qu'on
va pouvoir y mettre
je suis un peu inquiet des seuls six
semaines de travail pour arriver à un
résultat
donc les titres des groupes de travail
me parraissent satisfaisant cela peut
correspondre à des points très
importants pour refonder l'hôpital
public les maîtres mots pour nous c'est
la présence des usagers et la présence
de tous les personnels dans les
décisions et la nécessité de renforcer à
la fois les lits et le nombre de
personnels correctement pays
donc si ces choses là sont prises en
compte dans les jours qui viennent
qu'on ressent que tout de suite nous
sommes prêts le gouvernement est prêt à
faire ces efforts là et bien là
discussion va continuer et a priori ces
cinq groupes de travail
personnellement en tous les cas je n'ai
pas encore discuté avec mes collègues
peuvent permettre d'avancer il faut que
la volonté soit très clair en face nous
la volonté nous l'avons eu
nous avons posé sur la table un
manifeste avec un très grand nombre de
plaintes de propositions de plus de 50
pages qui peut tout à fait servir de
base à une réflexion forte
stéphane augé la dette des hôpitaux
publics français atteint aujourd'hui
près de 30 milliards d'euros c'est
évidemment énorme est ce que dans ce
travail vous avez tenu compte justement
de cette dette pour aller vers une
refonte totale du système et et entêtant
faire se peut de réduire des dépenses
lourdes des hôpitaux publics
je crois que je vous avais déjà répondu
comme ça il ya quelques mois je ne suis
pas économiste de la santé bien
évidemment des collègues ont travaillé
sur ce sujet il est difficile des pistes
avaient été déjà abordé par le
gouvernement comme entre autres le
rachat de la dette par le gouvernement
pour limiter les frais de la dette qui
est évidente qu'il va falloir investir
mais encore une fois monsieur le
président de la république a dit à
mulhouse
très clairement a employé des mots très
forts auxquels les soignants se sont
attachés très clairement il répète dans
nos services dans nos hôpitaux
donc oui il va falloir investir ça veut
dire trouver de l'argent j'aurais envie
de dire toujours une seule chose à son
endroit là quel est le marqueur qu'on
regarde pour comparer les résultats aux
investissements fourni et ses marqueurs
il existe dans l'organisation mondiale
de la santé ou ailleurs c'est la santé
de la population c'est le vieillissement
en bonne santé c'est moi je suis
pédiatre l'évolution et la prise en
compte des maladies chroniques
nous sommes très très loin des standards
internationaux aujourd'hui alors que
nous étions les premiers il ya encore
quinze ans si on se donne ces marqueurs
là qu'on s'en donne les moyens en
faisant attention à ne pas gaspiller
l'argent public
on peut y arriver donc il va falloir
trouver de l'argent on a proposé des
solutions elles ne sont sans doute pas
complète et des spécialistes en
proposerons d'autres
moi j'ai envie de regarder le résultat
je suis soignants je veux que les
enfants français tous mes concitoyens
puisque je suis pédiatre soient
correctement soignés et qu'on me demande
des comptes si je ne les soigne pas bien
avec les moyens que l'ensemble de la
société aura voulu donner choisissez
simplement sur qui m'intéressent
professionnels de santé ma dernière
question la mobilisation des hôpitaux le
16 juin à l'appel de douze syndicats et
collectifs et est conservé déterminez
vous voulez être dangereux
alors je ne sais pas vous répondre je
n'ai pas encore discuté avec mes
collègues je pense que pour l'instant je
n'ai pas eu de contre ordre je tiens à
signaler que dans de nombreux hôpitaux
et ça va un nombre croissant toutes les
semaines il y à une mobilisation
hebdomadaire dans l'ensemble des
personnels sur le parvis de leur hôpital
ça s'est passé à saint-etienne ça se
passe à robert debré ça va se passer à
saint-louis ça se passe à l'hôpital
tenon à paris
ça s'est passé dans de nombreuses autres
régions en france à toulouse depuis
longtemps qui portent les revendications
que je viens de vous donner la
donc nous continuons à être mobilisés
avec cette volonté de construire et
surtout pas d'être dans la dénégation
permanente nous avons apporté des choses
nous voulons montrer que nous avons
besoin de réponses fortes à ma
connaissance aujourd'hui cette date du
16 juin n'a pas été remise en cause du
tout merci stéphane augé chef du service
de réanimation pédiatrique à l'hôpital
robert debré d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france